i suppose rumors have been going around
haven't they for a couple of weeks about
this development but confirmation coming
just a couple of hours ago
yeah they certainly have and it is no
real surprise that there won't be any
overseas spectators
at either the olympics or the
paralympics this summer it's a decision
that's been foreshadowed by the japanese
media
for several weeks now and my
understanding is that the tokyo
organizing committee
felt like they had to come to this
decision to give the best possible
chance
for the olympics and paralympics to go
ahead this summer in any iteration at
all
nevertheless it will be upsetting to
those die hard fans who go to the
olympic host city
every four years and buy tickets to see
events there it's also upsetting for the
families of some of the competitors
some of these athletes will only go to
an olympics once in their career
and this would would have been a chance
for their loved ones
to see them at the very pinnacle of
their career on the biggest stage
at all but as i said no real surprise
um obviously with questions about
whether this olympics will go ahead
still raging now the tokyo organizing
committee have released a statement
explaining their decision they said the
kovid 19 situation
around the world is still very
challenging and a number of variant
strains have emerged
while international travel remains
severely restricted globally
based on the present situation it's
highly unlikely that entry into japan
will be guaranteed this summer
for people from overseas in order to
give clarity to ticket holders
parties on the japanese side have come
to the conclusion that they will not be
able to enter japan at the time of the
olympic and paralympic
games my understanding is that they'd
already sold approximately 1 million
tickets to
international spectators 4.5 million
tickets
have been sold to japanese spectators
with decisions still to be taken
or whether domestic fans will be able to
be inside those arenas
for the olympics and paralympics and
there's still
huge resistance in japan this olympics
taking place at all
and they've been several polls done now
which indicate an
overwhelming majority of people don't
want this olympics to happen in japan
and that's easy to understand because
japan has
kept this pandemic relatively under
control
they still have a horrific death toll um
around 8
700 deaths as a result of coving 19 but
that's nothing compared to the toll
we've seen it take
in europe usa central and south america
so you can understand why many japanese
people
don't want 15 000 athletes arriving in
tokyo
the world's most crowded metropolitan
area this summer
that's without considering the tens of
thousands of officials
journalists and media as well that would
be
arriving into japan um so the tokyo
olympic committee the japanese
government and also the international
olympic committee
still determined that this olympics will
go ahead in some shape or form